du tennis à 90 ans impossible gilbert
carré vous prouve le contraire revers à
une main suivie d'un coup droit si la
force n'est plus celle des débuts la
motivation reste intacte je joue deux
fois par semaine en double parce que
le job à l'aube de son anniversaire le
club de tennis de voisins-le-bretonneux
a tenu à le célébrer adversaire amis et
supporters tous ont fait le déplacement
autour de ce joueur de la première heure
il n'a jamais quitté le club depuis 1960
près de la création du club il n'a
jamais quitté toujours gentil toujours
égal à lui-même tout le monde le
respecte même s'ils créent l'admiration
de tout le monde en définitive ne serait
ce que personnage c'est vraiment
exceptionnel 1 la façon dont on y
pratique parce que ils jouent encore
assez bien il joue même très bien parce
qu'il fait débat le toujours placé alors
il ya moins de force que ce qu'ils
avaient dans le temps mais il renvoie la
balle il reprend les balles les balles
forts qui font pas peur
44 ans que ce passionné de tennis foulée
terrain du club de voisins véritable
pilier gilbert ne manque jamais de
surprendre par sa vitalité jeudi comme
chaque semaine il sera de retour sur le
court avec comme seul changement le
nombre de ces années